that's an unimaginably small number
what we have is 0.003 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24
25 26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33 6 6 3
that's Planck's constant and what I'm
leave enough are a load of other decimal
or a lot of other numbers here we've
just rounded that data up slowly each
country's up quantum mechanics is the
constant of Planck that tells us that
this is the smallest amount of action
that we have now action is actually
quite a difficult concept Planck's
constant is really it's a measure of
quantization it's something that comes
up in quantum mechanics and it's to do
with the fact that things in in the
world when you look on the small inner
scale when you look closely enough you
find actually they don't very smoothly
they don't vary continuously they take
on sort of discrete values and so for
example the energy of light given out by
an atom it doesn't give out light at all
frequencies it gives out light at very
particular frequencies and those
frequencies tend to be very close
together but actually there's only
particular values of energy that you can
give out and Planck's constant is really
what dictates how close together those
values are Planck's constant tells us
about how electrons orbit atoms I've
wondered about hitch and I've wondered
about the physical significance of age
I've never quite wondered why here it's
why it's called hitch and not W or Z ha
again I ought to know that is a similar
question to see ie
I don't know I don't know and no way
it's not called P because P is
convention used for momentum and one of
the key equations relating momentum and
wavelength is this so we couldn't call
Planck P as well so Planck was a very
famous German physicist considered by
many to be the
sort of God further the forefather of
quantum mechanics do you rate him oh yes
yeah I don't think it's a physicist
alive dead or to come that wouldn't
reeling so this is a second year
undergraduate experiment that is
actually used to measure to work out
what Planck's constant is we have a
mercury lamp here so with this of a lamp
which is filled with mercury gas and
we're actually putting electricity
through that to generate to excite the
atoms excite the electrons in those
atoms and those electrons bounce between
different states and they give off light
and so that's what we can see here we
can see the light coming out from the
mercury lamp then we've got a series of
lenses and slits to really control how
that where that light goes so over here
we've got a prism which splits that
light up into its constituent colors now
unlike sunlight where you know if you
take a prism and you split that up you
see a broad broad spectrum here what we
have are very well defined lines this is
a in effect a signature or fingerprint
of mercury then what we do is we take
those spectral lines and have to move
this tickle-tickle spectral lines and
what we have here it would have been
helpful if I'd set it up gqj you can
just edit this country so here we've
with the prism we've broken up the light
into its constituent colors we really
want to focus on one of those colors now
and so let's we're going to select the
grain we've got a slit here which
selects the grain out we've got a lens
back here which in turn focuses the
light onto this photodiode so we have
green light we have photons with a
particular energy coming into this photo
time what's inside this photodiode is a
metal the gray night comes in it
releases electrons and from looking at
the energy of those electrons we can
work out where Planck's constant is it
looks like ned kelly that diode to you
ned kelly's i guess I never thought
quite Bob stands now so H is equal to
six point six three by 10 to the minus
34 and my first year on any
undergraduate would kill me if
I didn't add the unittest jiggle second
now the reason that it appears small to
us is that we have very large objects
you know we weigh 80 kilos whereas atoms
are something like ten to the minus
twenty seventy loads that's the mass of
the proton the electron is even lighter
and down at that scale the the units
that we choose to express H in become a
little bit cumbersome and inconvenient
so if we were working out these things
on atomic scales then each would have a
much more convenient convenient and
easily more easily memorable value so
there's a really fascinating story
called while about a character called
mr. Tompkins which was written by a guy
a physicists of another very important
physicist called George Gamow back as I
believe in the 50s 40s or 50s and he mr.
Tompkins is a bank manager who goes
along to various different talks by
leading physicists and scientists of the
time and he sits through the lectures
and invariably halfway through the
lectures he falls asleep and he has a
dream and the dream is usually related
at the topic of the lecture and one of
those very popular mr. Tompkins stories
relates to what would happen if he it
wasn't this imaginably small number what
if it was larger and if it were larger
and if were large enough so that we
could see these quantum phenomena in the
in the real world and that would mean
that instead of being sort of solid
objects we would have way of like
characteristics so we would spread out
if I were to for example to walk through
the door because I'm now of wave-like
characteristics I would diffract
and so bits of me would go in different
directions